[Música]
estas imágenes fueron filmadas en vadia
un desierto que se extiende entre Siria
e Irak en este vasto territorio Soldados
del régimen de bachar al azar y sus
aliados
custodian los campos de gas y petróleo
mientras algunas células del grupo
estado islámico se reactivan preguntas
en este desierto también viven tribus
beduinas cuyos miembros arriesgan sus
vidas cada año para salir a buscar
trufas
al menos 156 recolectores de trufas han
muerto en badia durante la primavera de
2023 fueron Víctimas de ataques armados
de artefactos explosivos y de Minas
antipersona
[Música]
recolectar trufas es un ritual en el
desierto sirio de badía se hace todos
los años entre febrero y abril
[Música]
hablamos con dos hombres miembros de los
tribus beduinas a los que llamaremos
cada año en esta época empieza la
temporada de trufas las personas vienen
de distintas regiones se reúnen y van a
badían
después de los ataques más recientes
esos grupos empezaron a ir acompañados
Por las fuerzas de defensa nacional
las fuerzas de defensa nacional son una
milicia civil que surgió de tribus
locales
el régimen sirio les da armas para
luchar contra el grupo estado islámico
[Música]
son los encargados de proteger a los
recolectores de trufas
[Música]
a cambio de su protección ellos se
llevan el 50% de la cosecha de trufas
[Música]
las trufas crecen por debajo de la
tierra pero hacen grietas en la
superficie
los recolectores utilizan herramientas
contundentes para desenterrarlas es
fácil de hacer
[Música]
después son vendidas en los mercados
locales los precios cambian de un año a
otro
las trufas del desierto son menos
perfumadas que las de Europa la unidad
puede pesar hasta 2 kilos en el mejor
momento de la temporada el kilo puede
venderse a 38 dólares lo equivalente a
dos meses de salario mínimo en Siria las
trufas se suelen vender a los
comerciantes que a su vez las exportan
al extranjero
recolectar trufas es una actividad
lucrativa pero también peligrosa la
tribu benítmica led es una de las más
grandes de Siria
está armada y es Poderosa
se dice que el jefe de la tribu es
cercano al hermano de Vallarta cuando
van al Desierto los hombres de la tribu
son escoltados por los milicianos de las
fuerzas de defensa nacional
el 17 de febrero por la mañana los
miembros de benica salieron de alsugna
un pueblo alrededor del cual crecen unas
de las trufas más famosas de la región
cuando llegaron a dubaitte a unos 10
kilómetros de
lo empezaron a seguir un vehículo 4x4
Toyota Hilux y una moto
[Música]
los recolectores trataron de huir por el
desierto
en vano
los ejecutaron a sangre fría
fue una ejecución sumaria
en la cabeza quema ropa
entre los civiles que murieron había
niños de 13 años
ese día murieron al menos 46 miembros de
la tribu
16 pertenecían al mismo clan los
Ninguno de los grupos armados que operan
en la zona reivindicó el ataque los
medios estatales sirios señalaron al
grupo estado islámico como responsable
al menos cinco funcionarios del régimen
murieron en el ataque de alsucna
[Música]
para waters experto en terrorismo la
identidad de los atacantes está Clara
ese ataque ocurrió en la zona situada en
el exterior de según las fuerzas de
seguridad está controlada por el estado
islámico desde hace muchos años el hecho
de que ellos estuvieran en una zona
controlada por el estado islámico
refuerza la idea de que ese grupo sea el
responsable del ataque
sigue diariamente los ataques en el
desierto de badía desde que el grupo
estado islámico volvió a estar activo en
la región también trabaja con la ong
que registra las violaciones de derechos
humanos desde comienzos de 2019 se han
confirmado un poco más de 900 ataques
del estado islámico en la serie central
estamos acostumbrados a ver el estado
islámico como un grupo muy mediático que
reivindica todo lo que hace pero ya no
tiene territorio en 2015 el grupo estado
islámico estaba en su apogeo controlaba
territorios en Siria e Irak pero ante
los ataques aéreos llevados a cabo por
una coalición internacional y el avance
de las fuerzas kurdas en el terreno el
grupo yihadista terminó por batirse en
retirada y refugiarse en el desierto en
2020 hubo un fuerte aumento de los
ataques del estado islámico y en esa
época las células del estado islámico se
concentraron en el núcleo central muy
remoto en esa zona desértica ahora están
llevando a cabo una insurrección con
pequeños grupos de militantes bien
armados que se desplazan en moto o en
camionetas con ametralladoras hacen
ataques Relámpago todo el tiempo en
todas partes
en vez de reivindicar los ataques el
grupo estado islámico ha tomado la
costumbre de dejar que algunas víctimas
se escapen para que cuenten lo que pasó
conducían motos llegaron hasta nosotros
y nos dijeron tírense al suelo
acribillaron a los demás Pero a mí me
dijeron vete empecé a correr en todas
las direcciones me dijeron que no mirar
atrás
la frecuencia de los ataques aumenta la
severidad de los ataques aumenta y
finalmente el régimen Rusia e Irán
contraatacan
después de 12 años de guerra civil el
régimen de ahora controla la mayor parte
del desierto sirio
el ejército regular se encarga de los
contraataques lo respaldan las milicias
de las fuerzas de defensa nacionales las
fuerzas de liguá al cus y los aliados
rusos del régimen Rusia tiene bases
militares en la taquia y tartús empresas
rusas explotan campos de gas y petróleo
en el desierto según un documento
militar estadounidense filtrado en abril
la fuerza paramilitar rusa Wagner
también tiene una base en los
alrededores
también están los iraníes y las milicias
apoyadas por Irán que también incluyen a
las milicias sirias a los combatientes
extranjeros afganos y pakistaníes a la
gesbola lisvanesa y a grupos iraquíes
todos esos grupos están presentes están
desplegados a veces trabajan juntos
otras veces por separado pero todos
están en el centro de Siria
[Música]
en el desierto el otro blanco de los
ataques son los pastores y sus ovejas
como ocurrió el 16 de abril en la
provincia de deiresor bastión de la
tribu saraya
[Música]
llegaron algunos miembros de las fuerzas
de defensa nacional
y se lanzaron tras los atacantes
pero no tuvieron éxito
Las ovejas han sido una fuente de
financiación clave para el estado
islámico desde hace años a veces matan a
los pastores a veces solo se roban Las
ovejas las venden en el mercado negro o
en los mercados regulares de ovejas
es el jefe de la tribu busaraya este
diputado apoya al régimen de Damasco a
veces supervisa las operaciones de las
milicias de las fuerzas de defensa
nacional y de ligua al
los hombres van uniformados y están bien
equipados con ametralladoras pesadas
entregadas por el gobierno sirio
desde comienzos de 2023 la tribu
bucharaya ha sido blanco de al menos
cuatro ataques armados el 19 de marzo
hombres de las fuerzas de defensa
nacional que pertenecían a la tribu
busaraya estaban escoltando a los
recolectores de trufas
un grupo armado atacó a los recolectores
de trufas y los miembros de las fuerzas
de defensa nacional contestaron el
ataque
según nuestro observador dos civiles
murieron en ese ataque y un miembro de
las fuerzas de defensa nacional resultó
herido
las fuerzas de defensa nacional
patrullan con frecuencia en el desierto
de badía
en este video descubren unos escondites
dentro hay piezas de repuesto para motos
medicamentos
y armas
el estado islámico es más eficaz Cuando
nadie puede ver sus movimientos Cuando
nadie puede encontrar sus campamentos
sus escondites y guaridas todo eso se
pone en riesgo cuando los civiles se
desplazan por zonas tan remotas Entonces
qué hace ataca a los civiles
los secuestros también hacen parte de la
violencia en el desierto el 3 de marzo
unos jóvenes pastores de busaraya fueron
atacados por hombres armados los
atacantes robaron 100 ovejas y además
secuestraron a cuatro niños
[Música]
número desconocido contactó a uno de los
padres por WhatsApp y le pidió un
rescate de 20 mil dólares por cada niño
los padres de los niños secuestrados
aceptaron las condiciones de los
captores pero no han vuelto a tener
noticias desde entonces
con frecuencia los secuestros terminan
con el descubrimiento de los cuerpos
ejecutados utilizó el término ejecutados
Porque casi siempre los cuerpos están
alineados con heridas de bala en la
cabeza
en el desierto de badía las minas
antipersona y los artefactos explosivos
improvisados también cobran vidas casi a
diario son plantados por el grupo estado
islámico pero también por el régimen
sirio los habitantes hacen lo que pueden
para desactivar esos dispositivos
mortales
[Música]
el 2 de marzo una mina explotó debajo de
un camión a bordo había un grupo de
recolectores de trufas
fallecieron cuatro personas
el jefe de la tribu
pidió a la población que dejara de ir al
Desierto de bad y a buscar trufas
pero ellos no lo escucharon
la temporada de recolección de trufas de
2023 ha sido la más mortífera desde la
derrota territorial del estado islámico
en 2019 varios analistas consideran que
estos ataques hacen parte de la
estrategia del grupo terrorista le
permiten generar dinero mientras combate
a sus enemigos su objetivo es hacerse
más fuerte hasta considerar que tiene
poder suficiente para volver a emprender
la conquista del territorio
[Música]